okay thank you thanks everyone for
coming even though it's getting late so
I'm going to talk about these
comunitario proofs of concentration
balance this is based on joint work with
young hustler my student at ETH but a
lot of it is actually gonna be based on
a paper by employers and coverlets and
explain you what I mean
so what's the goal of this talk so to
explain you why why I decided to talk
about this I have to tell you a little
story so in 2010 in paliotta in Cabo
Nets gave kind of not as a main result
of a paper but kind of on the side or
also a kind of it was it was an
important part of the paper but it was
not the kind of story thing they gave a
combinatorial proof of the chan of path
and okay that was nice and then in 2011
I was working with mark ronson hard who
was at ETH then and and for a paper
which we were working on you needed a
version of the Chernoff bound okay and
we try to apply this usual chain of
proof okay so this value bound the
expectation of e to the T X and that
somehow didn't work out and then then we
saw this paper by important components
and we try to apply that proof and it
was fairly easy and so what I want to do
today is I want to give examples of this
proof because I think it happens fairly
often that we all have to prove chan of
bounds okay it happens very often that
you have to prove concentration and I
think this proof is just not known
enough so that maybe when it's useful
that then people don't know it then it
would be easier to prove bounds using
this technique so what this means is is
I mainly I'm gonna give you in some
sense new proofs of all theorems what's
the plan over all of the talk so first
I'm going to prove the basic chain of
bounds using this technique you will see
this is fairly simple then I'm gonna
prove a chain of bound for walk
expand the graphs using this technique
I'm gonna show how the techniques
collects to all the methods so there is
kind of a different moment based method
which is extremely similar and and you
will see the connection and finally I'm
gonna say something about polynomial
concentration so let's start make the
basic channels back okay so here is a
basic channel pound let's say we have n
random variables x1 to xn and they're
independent and uniform from 0 1 and
then the probability that you have more
than n over 2 times 1 plus epsilon ones
is that mostly to the minus epsilon
squared I know that so everybody has
seen this everybody has seen a proof of
this day I guess but even if you haven't
you're gonna see one now so what's the
proof idea the proof idea is extremely
simple it can be summarized in this one
sentence yes it says so if the if the
Chernoff bound would be not to be wrong
and in fact the probability that there
are random subsets of size epsilon n
that the probability that it only
contains ones would be too big that's
the whole idea
if you like me that doesn't help you
much so let's let's look at it in detail
let's give the folk so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna pick these random
variables x1 to xn and at the same time
we're gonna pick a set M which has size
exactly M so this the capital M has size
lower case m and lower case M is gonna
be chosen
roughly epsilon never and over for he
will see later why and then we
considered two events so we considered
the event which I call many ones so
that's the event that the number of
effects is at least n times 1 plus
epsilon over 2 so that's the event whose
probability we want to show a small many
wants then we consider a different event
I call it all in M so that's the event
that every X I for which I is in M is
all the Xin mr1 that's why the event is
called on em because nobody can remember
anything during a talk or at least I
cannot never remember these things let
me put these events or piers or you can
always look them up okay so far so good
now what we know is that the probability
that everything in aim is 1 so the
probability of all in em is at least the
probability that we have many ones times
the probability that everything in n is
a name if we have many ones right so the
probability that all elements in M or 1
is at least the probability that well
first to get many ones and then the
probability that everything in M is 1
given that they have many ones ok so
what can we say about these terms in
this equation well the first thing here
is obviously 2 to the minus n no matter
how we pick M the probability that all X
I in M which is of size exactly
lowercase M is 1 is 2 to the magazine
the second thing is as we draw in detail
on the next slide but maybe you can even
tell now is that the probability that
everything in M is 1 given that we have
many ones is at least 2 to the minus M
times 1 plus epsilon over 2 to the N now
show this in detail on the next slide
but once we have this well then we're
done
we cancel out the 2 to the minus M here
and we get that 1 is at least the
probability of getting many ones times 1
plus epsilon over 2 to the epsilon n
over 4 remember that M is epsilon to the
N over 4 M is excellent times n over 4
and this is exactly the chair of bad
so I just want to make sure that kind of
everybody sees this because and of its
it's very simple but if this if you
don't see this then the rest of the talk
well makes very little sense and it's
late on Friday so I don't know I mean in
total it's very simple let me say okay
the probability that everything in M is
1 is at least the probability that we
have many ones times the probability
that everything in M is 1 given that we
have many ones and then we own and then
we know this and we only need two
bounties so like let's do this okay
let's go to this last time we need to
show that if the M is roughly of this
size epsilon times n over 4 then the
probability that we have everything in M
is 1 given that we have many ones is 2
to the minus M times 1 plus epsilon over
2 to the M at least so how do we do this
well what we do with is we pick an
arbitrary we start with an arbitrary
string which has many ones it can string
which has many ones what I claim is when
you condition here on having many ones
in fact you can also condition on any
fake string which has many ones ok and
it will still be true ok this for it is
saying here we only need the probability
over the choice of him
so you pick a string with many one and
as the second step you cover it up so
you forget what the string what's the
only thing you remember is that it had
many ones so that the number of ones was
at least n times 1/8 plus epsilon over 2
and if you like me then you forgot with
this because I didn't tell you I was
going to cover it up so now and I was
talking a lot so now you know nothing
about the string except that previously
you probably counted and saw that it had
more once than zeros and now we're going
to randomly pick em one by one and on
comedy's okay so let's pick one random
this one so what's the probability that
on this one there's a 1 well we know
that there are more warmth than zeroes
right we know the
there are many ones that are at least an
half plus epsilon n over two at once ok
so there are epsilon anymore one since
zero so the probability of getting a one
is at least it's 1 plus epsilon over two
at least
okay and indeed when I uncover it I'm
getting a one so let's look at the next
one of the probability this one is a 1
well it's a bit smaller than before
right because we already uncovered one
of the ones but it's still pretty big so
okay we go on I'm covering each time
being lucky and as long as we don't I
mean as long as we are covered only that
many ones right n times epsilon over 4
then the probability of getting it one
in the next one is always going to be
somewhat big ok and I pick the parameter
so that in the beginning the probability
of uncovering a 1 is 1 plus Epsilon but
we only uncovered as many so that it
goes down to 1 plus epsilon over 2 so it
starts at 1 plus epsilon but then it
goes down slowly and we stop once it's
at 1 plus X you'll note so what this
means is that each time we uncovered a
new element the probability that the
uncovered element is 1 given that the
uncovered only wants so far and that we
have many ones I should have added that
many ones is at least 1 plus epsilon
over 2 over 2 1 plus epsilon half over 2
and so because we uncovered M elements
the probability that all in n or ones
given that we have many many ones is at
least 2 to the minus n times 1 plus
epsilon half to the N
and that's the whole proof
so questions to this
if there is another proof of Schmidt
sigil and Srinivasan mm-hmm yeah yeah so
I will I will say something about this
later actually I forgot to mention this
paper this is from 1995 and kind of the
calculations look very similar and we
will come to this in part three where I
can connect this to moments bounce and
we'll see how comic books are there okay
so again that the proof idea in some
sense it's very simple right the
probability of this chain of BAM must be
very small as otherwise the probability
that the subset of size epsilon n
contains only ones would be to be and if
you are careful then important
carbonates they show that you can also
recover for example this optimal
Chernoff bound with relative entropy
here that's very nice okay let's go to
then walks so what we're talking about
here is the following setting we have
given a D regular expanded graph okay
vertices V H as a and second eigenvalue
lambda and I normalize things so that
lambda is smaller than one okay the
first eigen value is 1 and the second
eigen values is smoking and we have a
subset W of the vertices of density mu
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna pick a random walk W 1 2 WN like
this we're gonna walk through the graphs
at random and we're gonna set variables
X I to be indicate to say that the F 1
is in the set W and what we're going to
show is the probability that the sum
over the X I of the walk is at least mu
N times 1 plus Epsilon that this
probability is much smaller than 1
that's so what we want to show is the
probability that at the number of times
you are in W that this is bigger than mu
times n which is the number which you
would expect on average
plus epsilon that this probability is
much smaller than table not smaller and
let me set the parameters here so we
have to set size okay
which we want to hate sometimes it's
it's mu the relative set size n is the
length of the walk and lambda is the
expansion constant okay which is
normalized so that it must be bounded
away from one okay so and then what one
can show is that in this above setting
we have that the probability that we
deviate by more than epsilon in this
sense is that mostly to the minus 1
minus lambda 1 plus lambda mu over 1
minus mu epsilon squared over N Oh 2
times 1 plus lower order terms where
they are lower order than M 0 so this
theorem again this is not new this was
previously no shown by Kahala in 97 even
though in this paper it was not stated
like this it was more stated you need to
minimize some expression but if you
minimize the expression you get this
okay and this is tight so if mu and
lambda in in the following sense okay if
I say it's tight I need to explain in
what sense it is tight so it's sent in
the is tight in the following sense so
first of all kind of the best you can
hope is that the probability that this
is more than such a thing is like e to
the minus some function of lambda mu
epsilon times the number of of steps in
the random walk times n okay so it's e
to the minus something times n because
it cannot go faster down than the name
okay and now this function what we claim
here this function in in front of the
end what we say here and and what you
can show is that this function if you
make epsilon smaller and smaller the
dominating term in epsilon is 1 minus
lambda 1 plus lambda mu 1 minus mu
epsilon square half so there are other
terms which are not important if epsilon
goes to 0 faster kind of then lambda and
view if you think of London music
constant and you make epsilon very small
and then n very big then this is tight
okay what we do here is we use this in
periodic open each technique and show
that the lid you can prove this using
this technique even tight expanded walks
can can be proven like
so so here's the theorem okay which I
kind of want to sketch the proof of in
the and talk so we kind of imagined that
we said you and lambda to be constants
and then what we want to show this that
the probability that some of times you
hit the set that probability that this
is more than mu n times 1 plus epsilon
this is exponentially small in it and
what we're going to do is we're going to
use the same technique as before so
again we have these two events ok the
probability that you have many wants
which is again this thing the
probability that for a random set M of
some size that everything in M is 1
which is this event here and we're gonna
break right down the same equation as
before simple so we say ok again the
probability that you hate everything in
M is at least the probability that you
get many ones times the probability that
you hit everything in M if you have many
ones now let's analyze these terms so it
turns out that this one right with this
covering proof which I gave before it's
exactly the same the probability that
everything in M is hit given that you
have many ones is still gonna be at
least new to the M times 1 plus epsilon
over 2 to the M as long as n is smaller
than kind of epsilon M and over 4 or
something and this certainly makes M
small enough so this is simply true so
the only thing we have to worry about
now is the probability that everything
in M is 1 ok so now the setting here is
we make a walk on an expander and we
pick some of the steps
okay we uncovered some of the steps and
we look ok are we in the state in these
steps and what we want to show is that
the probability that all of these are in
the steps is not too big ok so for this
we have this lemma so suppose that is to
pick a subset M of 1 to the N at random
then and of this exact size then the
probability that everything is an M is
roughly mu to the M I mean
loading some turtles depending on
epsilon which I will fill in later okay
so if M is not too big than in these do
you have this I'd like to quickly sketch
how to prove this lemma it's not too
difficult but I will stand up to the
whole proof so this is the lemma again
suppose I pick they said at random and
make that many steps then the
probability that all of the steps land
in the sake M over the choice of the set
m and the walk is that most something
like it did here so how do we do this
well let's first understand this
probability in case the set which we
pick like the position in the walk which
the uncover is fixed okay so let's
suppose that the set is fixed and and
let's write it in this way so the first
element in the set is d1 positive number
the second element is d1 plus 3/2 third
is element is d1 plus d2 plus d3 the
last element is d1 plus and so on plus
DM I can always write this set in this
way so what I claim is if you now fix
this so can you take the probability
over the walk only that everything is in
M is that mostest product of a new plus
lambda to the D I and how do you prove
this well you go and and you look what
other people prove and they prove this
so this is something which is kind of
hitting property of random walks okay so
it's well known that this is this is
this bound I forgot to write down the
reference so the summer know who proved
this but it's it's it's old result it's
very well-known it's kind of you do a
spectral technique so you just look this
up and you know
commotions em already I take
commercializing some yeah okay so this
is this is mellow new you kind of just
you just write the kind of the
probability distribution in the ISTEP as
a vector and you apply kind of you do
eigenvalue decomposition and you don't
have to do so much work so what does
this mean so what this means is that
what we need to show is that if we pick
D if we pick the same aim at random
right that basically the expectation of
this expression over the choice of the
set T is small and that's all we need to
do to get channel of bounds for random
walks on X but all we need to do is to
show now that expectation of this
expression when we pick a set M is small
and so okay this again this is all ready
to do and this is this will be very
simple if the di were independent
because then what you could do is you
could just exchange the sum and the
product sign okay and you could kind of
understand each individual term and the
individual terms or kind of so that it's
kind of obvious that they are small
because they are very bigger than and if
they are in expectation very bigger than
than one over one minus lambda and so
kind of if they were independent and it
would be would be obvious however
they're not independent right they are
kind of picked by this process and in
particular if the a one is huge and the
next one are going to be small so
they're not anything but don't despair
okay so we can always replace the di
with something smaller and that doesn't
break the bound and if we make fewer
steps on the random walk between to
uncover things then this only makes the
probability worse for us if we kind of
reduce the steps and what you can show
is that there is a joint distribution of
D 1 to the M and C 1 to C M some random
variable C 1 to C M so that the CI are
indeed smaller and they are in deep end
and they have a good property and that's
a fairly simple thing I mean it's kind
of very clear how you do it you need to
couple these two things and you get this
this bound so you need to think about it
and I thought okay should I should I
show this and I decided it's more
technical than insightful so I'll meet
the proof of this but it's kind of an
exercise I didn't check that I mean it
was not hard enough for me to check that
it's fairly easy to prove so you just
so now once you have this what you can
say is okay the expectation over the
same of these mu plus lambda to the D is
at most the expectation of M of the CI
where you can pick the CI
together then you exchanged as the
product over the psalm and then you get
this okay so let's let's look at it
again so the overview really follows for
for expanding box this simple recipe so
you do this means that okay you say the
probability that all in M is at least
the probability I get many went once
times the probability that all in am
given any ones then this right this
left-hand side is just the hitting
property for expounder walks which is
well understood and very easy to bound
and the right-hand side they just use
the randomness over here okay now let's
go to part three so this is connection
to moments and that I hope to answer or
loops question let's let's see so what
did we do we started with this basic
inequality probability that all in M is
at least the probability that many ones
times the probability that all in aim
given many ones and of course what we
really did is is we kind of just bounded
the probability that you have many ones
by this quotient and what we said
especially in the second part is okay
this Lowood poverty you can basically
always bound by mu to the M 1 plus
epsilon to the M or epsilon 1/2 to the N
and here here are adepts on half the n
so basically this was the basic
inequality which we used
and the statement was just kind of okay
if you can bound this then you get done
in any case is not a MOBA and now
another technique and here I reference
this paper by eons on Alyoshka bitching
routines keyboard I think this SSS paper
from 95 as on a point that and they do
the same thing so kind of but what they
do is okay let's look at this
probability which we want to bound and
let's just say that we take everything
on both sides to the power of M for some
M which we can translate so you can do
that it's gonna be the same probability
now let's do Markov okay so using Markov
inequality you get this so this means
that the probability you get many ones
is this expectation of 1 over N to the M
times the sum of X I to the M so that
this is a type where should be some X I
to the M okay the sum if the sum is
taken to the N power like here
so let's compared to its passions you
see they look fairly similar and why do
they look fairly similar well what's
this Psalm here
what's this expectation over sum over X
I to the M over m to the M well we
expand this this sum in here and we get
that it's 1 over N to the M s times the
sum over all indices e to the X I 2 e to
the X I M so now this ok you can imagine
that's like picking a set of size m at
random what bit repetition okay here now
you pick with repetition and then this
expression if we have seen a one random
variables it's just exactly one in case
all of the Xiao long it's exactly the
same except with repetition so this kind
of this kind of shows that there is this
connection and I think the SSS paper
maybe you know better but I mean they
have they've just adopted this you of
course this is kind of it leads to very
similar things and so what this means is
the two techniques are almost the same
but they simply Atsuko Burnett's trick
okay that's kind of one advantage in my
opinion it's very simple to understand
right I mean this very basic thing is of
simple to understand and I find it very
intuitive the other thing is also simple
to understand but I just find a moment a
bit less intuitive and one more
advantage which we exploit in the
expanded random walk proof for example
is that you have choice how to pick em
so you can either choose it with
repetition or without repetition and
it's not the same okay because if you
look at the lower side thing if you pick
em without repetition then it's always
going to be 1 plus epsilon to the M here
and not it's not going to go down if you
pick it with repetition it's gonna go
down so it's not exactly the same and
for example in the expound walk
technique it's it seems
easier to work without repetition and
then it seems easier to work with kind
of this view however at the moment it's
easier general lights if takes I or not
over over the zero one right I mean kind
of this holy name thing this is it only
makes sense if the random variables are
zero one random variables and and
otherwise you have to work something so
in the moments easily generalized okay
so I have some time left I think but not
ready so let's keep the polynomial thing
and come to the conclusions so what what
I just wanted to show you is this input
lots of covenant technique which is kind
of a very very simple thing which in my
opinion gives a nice way of proving
concentration bounds which I find very
intuitive and at least kind of for me
it's the way to teach them in class and
the technique is still powerful right it
can be used to give tight bounds for
random walks and expanders and in some
cases that the one I told you about in
the beginning at at least to me seems
easier than bounding this expectation
and however there is a very close
connection of the technique to bounding
the m's moment and just as a side remark
we have some reproving of all the bounds
using this
yeah I mean this is so what do you do
instead of him independence I mean yeah
so we be kind of the reason why we
needed the sort of proof at is proof in
the paper bit McRonald is also because
we did not really have independence so
we needed to eliminate this kind of yeah
the only assumption I need that is that
every set of size M the probability of
getting all ones is so that's assumption
is instead of independence okay I come
up find this like this in there in the
paper but that maybe I did not look at
it exactly enough
what's the statement of the powerless
that you were going to tell us about oh
yes okay so that from the abstract I
mean just know that it's kind of this is
okay yeah I don't even want to to show
it so exactly I mean there is this paper
by Kim in view in 2000 where they say
okay if you have a polynomial then under
certain conditions which I don't want to
go into now the value of the polynomial
is concentrated and using this technique
you can relatively easily prove this it
kind of somewhat different bounce at
least however the kind of there is there
is papers from 2012 for example where
they prove it using the old technique we
talking about so it's gonna I don't want
to go into it